S
ATTORNEYS 1 80. CNN'S K FILE,
JUST REVEALING MORE
CONTROVERSIAL COMMENTS FROM
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY IN THE STORMY
DANIELS HUSH MONEY CASE, JOE
TACOPINA. NOW WE'VE TOLD YOU
ABOUT SOME OF THE COMMENTS
TACOPINA MADE IN 2018 DEFENDING
MICHAEL COHEN'S CREDIBILITY AND
CALLING THE DANIEL SITUATION OF
PANDORA'S BOX THAT WOULD HAVE
BAD RESULTS FOR TRUMP. BUT THE
FAMED DEFENSE ATTORNEY ALSO
SUGGESTED THAT HE BELIEVED TRUMP
HAD THE AFFAIR WITH DANIELS,
WHICH, OF COURSE, TRUMP
REPEATEDLY DENIES. WE HAVEN'T
SEEN THEM SEND A TWEET OR
ANYTHING WHICH IS UNUSUAL. AND
BY THE WAY TO ME, IT MEANS YOU
KNOW IT'S TRUE RIGHT BECAUSE HE
HAS A THREAT TO SUE. RIGHT OUT
FRONT. NOW THE SENIOR EDITOR OF
CNN'S K FILE, ANDREW KACZYNSKI,
OF K FILE, ALL RIGHT, SO I MEAN
, IT'S AMAZING WHEN YOU TOOK THE
TIME TO GO THROUGH AND SO MUCH
THAT YOU FOUND THIS WAS NOT THE
ONLY TIME THAT WE JUST PLAYED
THERE THAT YOU FOUND TACOPINA,
SAYING THAT HE BELIEVED TRUMP
HAD AN AFFAIR WITH STORMY
DANIELS, WHICH, OF COURSE, IS AT
THE HEART OF TRUMP, SAYING
NOTHING HAPPENED HERE BECAUSE
HE'S SAYING HE DIDN'T HAVE AN
AFFAIR AND WHAT'S INTERESTING IS
YOU KNOW TACOPINA, IN ADDITION
TO BEING A WELL KNOWN CRIMINAL
DEFENSE ATTORNEY, HE'S ALSO A
WELL KNOWN CRIMINAL DEFENSE
COMMENTATOR. HE'S BEEN ON THIS
SHOW. HAS BEEN ON MANY SHOWS
OVER THE YEARS TALKING ABOUT ALL
SORTS OF LEGAL MATTERS. ONE OF
THOSE STORMY DANIELS 2018, AND
THERE'S TWO INTERESTING THINGS I
WANT PEOPLE TO LISTEN TO IN
THESE CLIPS WERE ABOUT TO PLAY
ONE IS HIM SPECULATING OVER THE
SITUATION. HIS PERSONAL OPINION
, AS WE WILL HEAR IS HE THINKS
IT'S TRUE. THE OTHER IS HIM,
SUGGESTING THAT THIS COULD BE AN
IN KIND CAMPAIGN CONTRIBUTION.
THESE ARE BOTH THINGS THAT HE
NOW SAYS ARE NOT TRUE. TAKE A
LISTEN TO THIS. NO ONE WAS HERE
IS GOING. OH MY GOD, I CAN'T
BELIEVE THIS SAID ALL ALONG IF
HE HAD JUST COME OUT AND SAID,
YEAH. I DID. SO WHAT? AND JUST
CHALK THAT UP TO ANOTHER ONE OF
THE THINGS ON HIS HIS LIST OF
MINOR SCANDALS. HE GETS THROUGH
THE GREAT DETAIL ABOUT HER ONE
NIGHT STAND WITH HIM. WHAT ELSE
CAN SHE SAY? THERE'S NOTHING
ELSE TO TELL. THIS COULD BE
LOOKED AT AS AN IN KIND
CONTRIBUTION AT THE TIME OF THE
ELECTION. THIS IS A REAL
PROBLEM. OKAY SO HE, AS YOU SAID
, CLEAR THAT HE BELIEVES THAT
THE AFFAIR HAPPENED AND CLEAR
THAT HE THINKS IT COULD BE AN
INCOME IN KIND CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTION AND A REAL PROBLEM
. SO NOW HE'S MAKING THE OTHER
SIDE OF BOTH OF THOSE ARGUMENTS.
BUT THIS IS NOT THE ONLY ISSUE
WHERE TACOPINA IS AT ODDS WITH
WITH TRUMP. SO YOU FOUND ANOTHER
CLIP FROM 2021 INTERVIEW WHERE
TACOPINA SAID VERY CLEARLY AND
STRONGLY THAT HE BELIEVES THAT
TRUMP DESERVES THE BLAME AND
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED. OVER THE
JANUARY 6TH INSURRECTION. SO
HERE'S THIS ONE THAT ANDREW
FOUND. WHY I DON'T THINK HE DID
ANYTHING CRIMINAL THAT I THINK
HE DID SOMETHING IMPEACHABLE.
YES I DO. WHEN YOU SAY TO A
BUNCH OF LUNATICS. A BUNCH OF
YOU KNOW PEOPLE WHO HAVE HAD A
PROPENSITY TOWARDS VIOLENCE
BEFORE THESE GROUPS THAT HAVE
GATHERED, YOU KNOW, WHICH WAS A
PLANNED GATHERING. HEY, GO TO
THE CAPITAL AND FIGHT. AND FIGHT
FOR WHAT? THE CAPITAL AND FIGHT
FOR WHAT IS FIGHT MEAN TO THESE
IDIOTS. WHAT DO YOU THINK IT
MEANT KILLED PEOPLE. HE SAID IT
BEAUTIFULLY. AND YOU KNOW WHAT'S
INTERESTING ABOUT ABOUT THIS GUY
IS HE IS NOT JUST TRUMP'S
ATTORNEY LEGALLY. HE IS ALSO
TRUMP'S ATTORNEY IN THE COURT OF
PUBLIC OPINION. WE HAVE SEEN
THIS GUY ON CNN. WE'VE SEEN THIS
GUY ON GOOD MORNING AMERICA ON
FOX NEWS. HE IS OUT THERE. UH
YOU KNOW, WRAPPING TRUMP, SO IT
IS REALLY INTERESTING TO HEAR
HIM. COMMENTING ON TRUMP
COMMENTING ON CAPITOL RIGHT
BEFORE HE WAS LEGALLY
REPRESENTING HIM. WE DID. REACH
OUT TO HIM. WE ASKED HIM ABOUT
THIS, HE SAID. HE SAID HIS MIND
HASN'T CHANGED ON THE ISSUE.
WHAT CHANGED IS THAT HE LEARNED
THE FACTS. OKAY THAT'S
INTERESTING, BUT THESE ARE
REALLY INTERESTING TO HEAR. I
MEAN, AND IT'S CLEAR IT'S CLEA